rush limbaugh died on wednesday at the
age of 70. though his lung cancer
diagnosis
has been publicly known for months of
course still his death has managed to
feel somehow
shocking that's that's how it always
feels when a man of great
consequence and importance reaches the
end of his
of his time here on earth and that's one
thing that nobody can deny about
rush limbaugh russia russia's life it
was important it was an important
consequential life
he was a pioneer a legend he changed the
country
in ways that few media figures ever have
ever could ever will anyone who doubts
russia's profound
importance need only take a glance at
social media
and there they'll find of course many
people paying grateful tribute to the
radio
icon and talking about him and all the
ways that they were personally motivated
by him and
influenced by him and shaped by him but
um another and perhaps more profound
indication of russia's importance
is that all of the worst people in the
country many of the most
vile and disgusting ghouls that our
culture has produced
have come out to celebrate his death
openly and to dance on his grave without
shame
i'm not going to amplify any of these
people individually by going through a
list of all of the
filthy disgusting things they're spewing
suffice it to say that the phrase
rotten hell and rest in piss
were trending minutes after news broke i
mean minutes after news broke of
russia's death
right away these are not just random
anonymous internet trolls either
i mean there are a lot of those but also
some of the most prominent left-wing
voices who
when they're not laughing at a man for
dying of cancer who are busy lecturing
us about the need for
civil political discourse media outlets
showed similar lack of restraint rolling
stone's headline read quote
rush limbaugh right-wing radio host who
trafficked in bigotry and cruelty
dead at 70. the daily beast was only
slightly more subtle saying rush
limbaugh the human megaphone who
hijacked the gop
dead at 70. and of course the fever's
fever swamps of the left-wing
blogosphere
were not subtle at all jezebel's top
headline was simply
good riddance in other words the media
and the left have showed the grace
dignity
poise compassion that you'd expect which
is
none at all rush i think deserved better
than
to have the story of his death become a
story about the jerks who are rejoicing
over it but it is worth
thinking about this now familiar routine
we live in a country where this sort of
thing happens so automatically that we
aren't shocked by it anymore
when a famous person of a certain
political id uh persuasion
certain ideological persuasion dies we
expect
that satan and hell will be trending on
twitter because of all the
users openly fantasizing about their
political enemy
roasting eternally in a place that by
the way they don't even think exists
and that's exactly what happened in in
in russia's case right on cue but
why does it happen it seems insufficient
to chalk it up to mere partisanship
mere divisiveness what's really fueling
it
to answer that question the first thing
we have to establish is that this
is truly a left-wing phenomenon i'm not
claiming that
nobody on the right did any football
spiking
or made any jokes about the death of
ruth bader ginsburg or some other
recently deceased liberal okay what i'm
claiming
is that those reactions were
representative of a definite minority
on the right there has not been a time
in my memory correct me if i'm wrong
when rest in piss or anything like it
was trending in reaction to the death of
a famous prominent left winger
when does that ever happen for the most
part
rbg was eulogized respectfully both by
the left and the right
there are notable exceptions but those
exceptions are just that exceptions
on the left the respectful eulogy of
political opponents has become itself
the exception
an exceedingly rare exception
shameless celebration is the norm now
it's it's what you expect
to see and it's what you do see
what drives this i think is the same
thing that drives cancel culture to a
great extent
it's the belief again not totally unique
to the left but more prevalent by a wide
margin on the left
that people with differing views are bad
people
not just that they have bad opinions bad
ideas but they
that they themselves are bad deep down
in their souls
the consequence of casting every
political disagreement
every alternate opinion every opposing
argument as
racism or sexism or homophobia or
transphobia or whatever other ismophobia
is that those those who are conditioned
into thinking this way will come to
believe that their opponents are truly
and
irredeemably evil so it's easy to make
jokes as i have many times about the
fact that the left calls everything and
everyone bigoted right
but the not so funny reality is that a
great many americans especially younger
americans
really believe this framing they really
believe it
they've taken it to heart it is the lens
through which they view
reality they look out at the world
and they see millions of wicked
worthless racist
knuckle-dragging subhumans staring back
at them that's the world they see
they don't recognize the humanity of
their opponents they certainly cannot
see any goodness or virtue in them
the reaction to rush limbaugh's death is
not happening in a vacuum
it's not a matter of random anonymous
trolls simply trying to get a rise
out of people it's a reflection of our
culture and of the ideological divide
and of how deep that divide is
and of the pure unbridled hatred
that has helped to carve it rush was
the relentless target um of this equally
relentless hatred for much of the past
four decades
as i'm sure he expected that has not
changed after his death if anything is
just ramped up
the man achieved many great things and
made his mark in many
countless and incalculable ways but one
of the deepest
testaments to his life is that these
sorts of people
are rejoicing over its end
may we all have hope to have that kind
of impact
on the world well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content